this video has been made possible thanks
to conflict of Nations in this episode
of visualpolitik we are going to talk
about a very serious topic nuclear
weapons and we are going to talk about
them in an incredibly sensitive context
this is probably the first time since
the Cold War there has never been so
much possibility of them being used I
know it might seem strange for some
people to talk about war video games
when we are witnessing a real war every
day on our screens but make no mistake
conflict of Nations is a video game that
like chess doesn't actually hurt anyone
it's the ideal Pastime for those of us
who like to spend some time speculating
on the defensive capabilities of
different countries without having to
actually harm anyone we wish Vladimir
Putin had devoted his free time to
conflict of Nations instead of
destroying the lives of so many people
in conflict of Nations you will be in
control of the Armed Forces of one of
the world's leading Nations manage the
economy diplomacy weapons research and
Troop mobilization to lead your nation
to Victory once you have an account you
can play the game on PC or mobile and
now the best of all you can unlock your
exclusive gift of 13 000 units of gold
and get one month of Premium
subscription for free by clicking the
link in the description this offer is
only available for 30 days so be quick
and start mobilizing your troops and
planning your battle
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Vladimir Putin is obsessed with history
books particularly and I'm sure this
comes as no surprise with all those
dealing with the Imperial past of Mother
Russia and keep in mind it's not just
about the reading in the Kremlin and in
general throughout Russia Putin has
placed statues of historic monarchs such
as Peter the Great and Catherine the
Great and this visualpolitik viewers
gives us many Clues as to what is
happening why well precisely because
these two Russian monarchs conquered a
good part of what we know today as
Ukraine for Russia of course Putin takes
it much further for him Ukraine is
indisputably part of Russia and
therefore so are its history and its
people for example in 2016 just outside
the gates of the Kremlin Putin had a
statue of Vladimir the Great who was the
Grand Prince of the principality of Kiev
in the 10th Century erected of course
for Putin Prince Vladimir was a
full-blooded Russian in fact the very
same Russian who embraced Christianity
and filled the national Spirit of what
is today Mother Russia so it makes no
sense to talk about the history of
Ukraine in fact in 2008 Putin himself
told us President George Bush that
Ukraine is not a real country and not
the eve of the cruel Invasion that
unleashed the terrible War we are
witnessing today on Ukrainian territory
he accused Vladimir Lenin of betraying
and destroying the Russian Empire by
creating a new Republic the Soviet
Socialist Republic of Ukraine along with
13 other republics beside Russia and you
know what everything indicates that he
sees himself as the leader the one
responsible for rebuilding the Russian
Empire
this same Vein on the 9th of June 2022
at a meeting with young entrepreneurs
Putin said two things firstly that
Ukraine is not and never will be a
sovereign country he even spoke of a
colony and secondly he compared himself
to Peter the Great when he fought the
Great Northern war against Sweden for 21
long years to restore Russia to
Greatness now this is visualpolitik and
not some history class of course history
can play a very important role but the
past can never predetermine the present
or the future regardless of whether or
not Ukraine was part of Russia or
whether or not its inhabitants speak
Russian today it is an independent and
sovereign country just as the United
States Australia Canada and Ireland are
independent from the United Kingdom
they're passed as part of the British
Empire and the fact that they speak
English does not give London any
historical rights but the Russian leader
doesn't give a damn about any of this
[Music]
foreign
in 2021 he published A Treatise of about
5000 words on the historical Unity of
Russians and ukrainians a document in
which Putin argues that Russians
belarusians and ukrainians form one and
the same people which Moscow now has to
reintegrate by hook or by crook mostly
by Crooks and that is exactly what Putin
attempted on the 24th of February when
he launched what he thought would be a
swift successful and glorious invasion
of Ukraine
of course as we all know what happened
next was totally different right now
Putin no longer has the opportunity to
be the builder of the new improved
Russian Empire but rather to be the one
responsible for sinking the motherland
his campaign in Ukraine has shattered
the Russian army which is now going from
defeat to defeat and has even lost the
flagship of the Black Sea Navy to make
matters worse he is now on the way to
sinking the national economy as well
Vladimir Putin is becoming the worst
enemy of Russian imperial ambition the
disaster has been so great that of the
190 000 troops that made up the initial
Invasion Force the casualties between
dead and wounded are estimated at about
one hundred thousand the Russian
military has performed worse than I
could ever have imagined it is too early
to plan a Victory Parade here but I
think that ukrainians are on the verge
of achieving irreversible momentum as
long as we the West continue to stand
with them Ben Hodges former Commanding
General of the U.S armies in Europe a
good example of the campaign is the
Strategic city of cupiansk on the banks
of the oskill river it's an important
Crossroads of railroads and Roads
[Music]
well for 195 days this city not only
lived under Russian occupation but also
became one of the most important centers
of the Russian military Administration
critical supplies to the front lines
were organized and passed through here
it was one of the key strongholds in the
Moscow War Machine and yet on 10th of
September 2022 the 92nd mechanized
Brigade of Ukraine captured this city
and set the blue and yellow flags flying
again unbelievable but true
another example well there is the case
of casson the city was filled with
posters saying that the city would be
Russian forever Russia had even gone so
far as we will see later to Annex it
along with most of the oblast however
despite the annexation the posters and
all that had been announced eight months
after occupying it the Russians had to
withdraw and the city has become
Ukrainian again
but as I said the worst for Russia may
be yet to come International sanctions
are damaging the Russian economy the oil
price cap may end up sinking government
revenues and many young people have died
in the war or are fleeing Russia and
many countries are already suspending
large contracts with Russian industry
for example Indonesia and the
Philippines have canceled large military
contracts with Russian industry in the
case of Indonesia we're talking about a
multi-million dollar contract for the
purchase of Sukhoi 35 Fighters aircraft
that will now be replaced by French and
U.S equipment Indonesia's 22 billion
dollar purchases of U.S and French
fighter jets how Russia's su-35 lost out
Indonesia's about face from a deal with
Russia to new purchase agreements with
the US and France highlights the potency
of U.S sanctions and that's not the end
of it what's more the international
position is becoming increasingly
delicate
foreign
without digging too deep a commission of
inquiry of the United Nations Human
Rights Council has published a very
harsh report accusing the Russian
Federation of committing multiple war
crimes during The Invasion we are
talking about executions torture rape
and of course the constant bombing of
Civilian areas and infrastructure that
is to say the Russian account is broken
all over the place and to make that as
worse the front is getting worse day by
day if the ukrainians keep pushing and
Western Aid keeps coming Russia risks a
catastrophic defeat which could spell
the end of Putin himself and given this
situation there is one question that has
spread to the Four Winds would Russia be
willing to escalate to the conflict and
if necessary use nuclear weapons could
this turn the tide of the war can the
Kremlin reach a peace agreement that
will allow it to save face well let's
take a look
final bullet
on 30th of September 2022 the Russian
president signed the incorporation of
the Ukrainian uplasts of luhank's
Donetsk zaparisia and kerson into the
Russian Federation it was at least
formerly the largest forcible seizure of
territory in all of Europe since the
second world war you could say that
Putin's objective with this annexation
was to demonstrate to the Russian people
that the war was making some sense that
far from being a defeat Russia was
gaining territory the problem is that it
is not exactly happening that way while
it's true that Russia has not delimited
the territory it has annexed which seems
like a bad joke the Ukrainian offensive
on keson and the expulsion of Russian
troops east of the danipa river has
still been humiliating while Russian
propaganda stated to the world and also
to the Russians themselves that kerson
would forever be a Russian city today it
is no longer so and take note because
following the annexation and from the
Russian point of view the Ukrainian
offenses are already being directed
against Russia's own territory so what
does this mean well theoretically and
according to kremlin's own rules Moscow
is now losing the war at home therefore
it is no longer possible to speak of a
special operation
the problem visualpolitik viewers is
that Vladimir Putin is like a poker
addict who always always raises the
stakes that at least has been the
experience so far for now he is losing
every hand and this has set off many
alarm Bells 20th of November 2022 Kiev
says it is preparing 425 shelters in
case of Russian nuclear attack cornered
humiliated defeated changing the course
of the war seems practically impossible
but could Putin's regime attempt a
nuclear strike that would force the west
and Ukraine itself to negotiate a
ceasefire could the Kremlin take its
pressure to the nuclear extreme so that
the war ends now and Putin can boast to
the Russians on the games achieved and
keep in mind that we are not talking
about any irrational hypothesis
foreign
Russia has destroyed its Army in Ukraine
but it still has one strength its
nuclear Arsenal and we are no longer
talking about large nuclear bombs
capable of wiping out entire cities and
regions instead its Arsenal comprises
about 2 000 tactical nuclear weapons of
between 1 and 10 kilotons these are
generally much smaller weapons that have
never been used in combat but were
designed not to raise a city to the
ground but to engage a conventional Army
on the battlefield an Arsenal that Putin
and the kremlin's top brass could
consider using in a moment of
desperation as a coup de force we have
our own military potential if someone
thinks that we will not use it if there
is a serious threat then he is wrong
Dmitry novikov Deputy chairman of the
Duma Foreign Relations Committee let's
imagine that Russia is forced to use its
most formidable weapons against the
Ukrainian regime which has committed a
large-scale Act of aggression that is
endangering the very existence of our
state I believe that NATO will not
interfere directly in the conflict even
in such a scenario Dimitri Medvedev MP
Putin himself threatens to use nuclear
weapons right at the beginning of the
invasion check it out Russia remain
means one of the most powerful nuclear
States moreover it has some advantage
and a number of cutting-edge weapons in
this context there should be no doubt in
anyone's mind that any potential
aggressor will face defeat and ominous
consequences if it directly attacks our
country Vladimir Putin and with the
arrival of autumn came major setbacks
from the battlefield threats from the
Kremlin multiplied and that helps
explain new stories like this 10th of
November 2022 top U.S general urges
diplomacy in Ukraine while Biden
advisors resist General Mark a Meli the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
has made the case that the ukrainians
should try to cement their gains at the
bargaining table
the 23rd of November 2022 war in Ukraine
Emmanuel macron announces that he will
have a direct contact with Vladimir
Putin in the next few days significant
Ukrainian advances that have put Russia
on the ropes have for the first time
multiplied pressure to negotiate a
ceasefire and stop the conflict from
escalating further and the question is
if Russia is losing the war why on Earth
not dip into its nuclear Arsenal well
visualpolitic viewers there are six good
reasons why Russia is unlikely to use
its nuclear Arsenal on rather six good
reasons why resorting to nuclear weapons
would be a tremendous mistake for Russia
so listen up
foreign
[Music]
to avoid defeating Ukraine may make some
sense until this matter is analyzed
calmly the truth is that there are good
reasons to believe that Moscow will not
use nuclear weapons in Ukraine in
particular we can highlight six major
ones firstly there are better military
Alternatives let me explain in the event
of resorting to the use of nuclear
weapons as a show of force The Logical
option would be the use of tactical
nuclear weapons against the Ukrainian
Army however contrary to what we might
think the use of these weapons would
escalate the conflict while at the same
time being unlikely to gain any military
advantage
[Music]
tactical nuclear weapons are usually
fitted to small Warheads that are
designed to attack large and
concentrated combat forces for the
Ukrainian Army does not operate with a
large concentration of troops and is
constantly on the move so damage would
be limited in fact for weapons below 10
kelotons their effects are outweighed by
high Precision artillery and thermobaric
weapons that have already been used at
the front
and so defeating Ukraine's military
capability would require the use of
dozens and dozens of tactical nuclear
weapons for example U.S military plans
during the Cold War called for 136
tactical nuclear bombs to clear out a
100 kilometer or 60 mile front the
current front between Ukraine and Russia
stretches for more than 600 kilometers
or 373 miles the nuclear weapons are
most useful to them when they don't use
them there is simply no battles field
advantage to using a nuclear weapon
retired General Ben Hodges former
Commanding General of U.S forces in
Europe of course these weapons could be
useful for attacking power plants and
infrastructure but their use would incur
a greater number of consequences without
offering significant advantages and this
brings us directly to the second reason
[Music]
the use of nuclear weapons could not be
the end of the problem for Russia but
rather the opposite it would be the end
of the solution the use of nuclear
weapons of any caliber would bring
resounding International condemnation a
condemnation far greater than that
caused by the war itself the pressure
against Russia would be so great that
sanctions would be generalized all over
the world including secondary sanctions
that would make relatively friendly
countries such as India or the United
Arab Emirates unfriendly Western
pressure would reach unimaginable levels
and Russia would become a radioactive
country so to speak something like a new
North Korea which of course would be a
death blow for Russian citizens and for
the country's own oligarchs and managers
who would no longer be able to find
Refuge
foreign
and even countries like China have
already made it clear that this is a red
line why because if Russia uses nuclear
weapons non-proliferation agreements
would go out the window many Southeast
Asian countries would jump headlong into
developing their own nuclear weapons as
life insurance and all this mess would
happen without gaining any military
Advantage for Russia
we are not only talking about political
or economic reactions perhaps there
would also be a military one Washington
has been very clear the use of nuclear
weapons would entail a forceful response
from the West this is something that
both the Secretary of Defense Lloyd
Austin the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff General Mark milley and the
National Security adviser Jake Sullivan
have made sure to convey to senior
Russian officials we have communicated
directly privately at very senior levels
to the Kremlin that any use of nuclear
weapons would have catastrophic
consequences for Russia that the United
States and their allies will respond
decisively and we have been clear and
specific about what that would entail
Jake Sullivan White House National
Security advisor we do not know exactly
what kind of response Sullivan is
referring to but what has been leaked is
that in the event of a nuclear attack
NATO would respond with a large-scale
conventional strike to destroy Russian
forces in Ukraine and guarantee
Ukraine's sovereignty
another possible response could be to
provide Ukraine with much more advanced
and lethal equipment for example
long-range strike equipment or even an
entire Air Force and it is clear that if
this response occurs the result could be
the annihilation of Russian forces in
Ukraine as far as we know Putin is
threatening to use tactical nuclear
weapons on Ukrainian soil not to attack
NATO which means that NATO should
respond in a conventional manner but the
response would be devastating and I
guess this is the clear message that the
NATO alliance is sending to Russia at
the moment The biganu Rao Minister of
Foreign Affairs of Poland we have all
seen what happened to the conventional
Army on the face of it Russia should
have been able to quickly defeat Ukraine
but corruption lack of equipment
training shortfalls and poor maintenance
have made the war a nightmare well let's
be clear Russia's nuclear weapons are
unlikely to be in much better shape than
its conventional forces and can you
imagine what a mistake or failure in
using these weapons would mean it could
mean the death blow for the Kremlin and
it could even end up damaging its own
military and bear in mind that this is
no slim chance Russia is a country where
we find new stories like this it
December 2020 Russian doomsday planes
radio equipment stolen by thieves
thieves have stolen electronic equipment
from a Russian military aircraft known
as a doomsday plane for its role in the
country's nuclear Arsenal local media
report and naturally there is a risk
that the escalation would be exponential
this is the fifth reason
since the Cold War it has been clear
that nuclear weapons were devices of
deterrence not aggression the use of
nuclear weapons could end up causing
unimaginable damage to all that was the
balance of mutually assured destruction
in which the Russian bigwigs themselves
have been trained all are aware of the
consequences and all have families and
friends in fact that makes the use of
nuclear weapons unpopular at home as
well for example Igor Ivanovic strelkov
a paramilitary leader who was
instrumental in the seizure of Crimea
and the donbass war has made it clear
that the use of nuclear weapons would be
a mistake and even a crime all these
reasons help explain why nuclear weapons
have never been used to gain neither in
the Korean War nor in the Vietnam War
nor in Afghanistan nor in the Ukrainian
War itself despite the fact that Russia
has already lost tens of thousands of
men the consequences could be so severe
that even if Putin were to lose his hit
the incentive to rein him in would be
very great evidently if history teaches
us anything it is that reality can end
up outweighing any possible scenario and
so visualpolitik viewers beyond the
world of the insane it is unlikely that
Russia will ever dip into its nuclear
Arsenal be that as it may the problem is
that Ukraine cannot afford a false start
a peace agreement without major
concessions from Russia could
permanently Doom this country and that
is something ukrainians would find hard
to accept but having reached this point
it's your turn do you think Putin's
Russia will dare to use nuclear weapons
do you think the end of the war may be
near leave us your thoughts in the
comments and now if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like And
subscribe to visualpolitik also remember
that if you want to feel like Sun Tzu
and speculate on Military strategies the
free online PVP strategy game conflict
of Nations is worth checking out click
on the link in the description to get
your unique starter pack but remember
that the offer is only available for 30
days all the best see you next time
foreign
[Music]